This episode of Real Engineering is brought
to you by Skillshare, home to over 16,000
classes that could teach you a new life skill.
By the time we reach our 80s, our hearts have
beat over 3.3 billion times and and have pumped
250 million litres of blood around the body,
enough blood to fill 100 olympic sized pools.
Just 3 weeks after conception the first muscle
cells of the heart begin to contract and don’t
stop until the moment we die.
It is quite frankly a marvel that our hearts
can last so long.
Pick up a stress ball and see how many times
you can squeeze it before arm starts to cramp
and tire.
Unlike skeletal muscle, cardiac muscle has
much higher numbers of mitochondria, which
provide the vital energy needed for contractions,
and a rich supply of oxygenated blood, it
never has to worry about the build of lactic
acid from working when deprived of oxygen.
But just because they do not fatigue does
not mean they are invincible.
Heart disease is one of the leading causes
of death in the world, as we grow older some
parts of the heart can deteriorate and cause
some problems, but we have developed some
incredible technology that has extended our
lives.
One of the most common implants in the world
being pacemakers, small implantable devices
that help keep our hearts beating when our
natural systems need some help.
Before seeing how they are implanted and how
they work, let’s first see how our own bodies
have been engineered by nature to keep our
blood flowing.
The heart has two sides separated by an inner
wall called the septum.
The right side of the heart, which on this
diagram is on the left, pumps blood to the
lungs where it is oxygenated and then travels
back to the heart where it is pumped by the
left side to the rest of the body.
The walls of the left side are much thicker
and stronger because of it has to pump blood
around the entire body, whereas the right
side just has to pump it to the lungs and
back.
The heart consists of 4 chambers the left
and right ventricles and the left and right
atria, the atria and ventricles are separated
by valves.
At the start of the heart beat all 4 chambers
are relaxed and the valves are open.
Blood flows into the heart from large veins
and the heart reaches max capacity.
Just here there are a bundle of cells called
the Sinoatrial node that are capable of producing
a electric impulse that will travel through
the heart and cause it to contract in a specific
order.
First the impulse travel to the AV node located
here, where it triggers both atria to contract,
squeezing blood out of the atria into the
left and right ventricles.
The electric impulse has now travelled down
through the heart to fibres located in the
ventricle walls that now cause them to contract,
as the pressure rises it forces these valves
to shut and prevents blood from flowing backwards.
You can see each of these stages on the classic
electrocardiogram.
The first little bump is the atria contracting,
followed by the spike of the stronger ventricles
contracting and finally there is another little
bump as ventricles recover.
For most, this sequence of events goes unnoticed
thousands of times a day.
But some may need a little help controlling
their heart beat. sometimes the Sinoatrial
node’s ability to set the correct pace breaks
down, leading to slower heartbeats or long
pauses between heartbeats.
There are a range of reasons why you may need
help and this is why the incredible pacemaker
was invented.
And as with most medical inventions it started
as an incredibly dangerous and scary device.
The first being invented by Albert S Hyman
in the 1930s.
It consisted of a hand cranked spring motor,
which would store the hand crank rotation
as potential energy in a spring.
This spring motor then drove a generator,
with these large U-Shaped magnets providing
the magnetic flux needed to generate a direct
current voltage.
The current was then pulsed by a rotating
interrupter disk with four conducting pads
which intermittently made contact with a brush
which supplied this huge needle electrode.
Amazingly this little machine was portable,
but it proved ineffective due to the low voltage
output.
His work was ultimately abandoned, but other
researchers recognised its potential after
the second world war.
A method of inducing hypothermia by cooling
the heart until it stopped beating to allow
it to be worked on during surgery was being
investigated, but upon rewarming it was found
that the heart needed help with controlling
heart rate as metabolic function recovered.
And John A. Hopps developed this device for
the job, delivering impulses at the desired
rate through paddles that were placed inside
the chest cavity during surgery near the Sinoatrial
Node.
The potential of using such a device on patients
suffering from heart defects at normal temperatures
was soon realised, but repeated applications
of high voltages cause muscle pain and twitches,
along with burns.
Making it unsuitable for extended use.
What we needed was an implantable device.
Hopps developed a catheter electrode, which
removed the need for open chest surgeries
by passing the electrodes through the subclavian
vein and into the heart.
On halloween night 1957 a power outage struck
a minneapolis hospital, leaving several young
patients without pacing from the mains powered
pacemakers, killing one of the children and
pushing famed heart surgeon Dr. C Walton Lillehei
to request the hospitals technician Earl Bakken
to develop a battery powered pacemaker.
He returned with this device, a wearable pacemaker
powered by mercury batteries that would launch
Earl Bakken’s company Medtronic into the
fortune 500.
This was a revolutionary device, but the need
to pass the wires through the skin was a constant
infection risk.
What was needed was a fully implantable device
and with continual improvements to transistors
allowing for the miniaturization of circuitry,
and improvements to batteries this was soon
realised.
This was the first ever fully implantable
pacemaker, created and implanted in Sweden
to save Arne Larsson’s life.
With a rechargeable nickel-cadmium battery,
which was charged through this induction coil
overnight about once a month.
It utilized some of the first silicon transistors
imported into Sweden, allowing it to use less
energy over older Germanium transistors.
All this was encapsulated in a biocompatible
epoxy resin.
Arne Larsson survived to 86, with his pacemaker
being replaced a total of 25 times over the
course of his life, as the technology improved
incrementally. [5]
Current generation pacemakers are now smaller
and more reliable than ever.
Medtronic have even developed the world’s
smallest pacemaker which is implanted directly
into the right ventricle without any cables,
and eliminating the need for the pacemaker
to be implanted under the skin, which can
lead to discomfort.
Over 700,000 pacemakers are implanted worldwide
every year.
[2] These devices help people live healthier,
happier lives and have advanced so far that
many can practically forget that they suffer
from heart disease.
This subject is something I spent 4 years
studying to work with, and have worked in
the medical device industry in the past with
Medtronic.
I am however completely self taught in illustration
and animation.
I designed this logo over 3 years, and today
I am happy to unveil the new updated version
which someone who actually knows what they
are doing designed.
I essentially just traced a gear tooth and
attempted to make it look like the font I
was using, with no real design experience.
I may have fared better with making look professional
if I watch some of these skillshare classes
on logo design first.
They teach simple things about shape, type
and colour, which I just had no idea about
at the time.
Something as simple as fixing the symmetry
of height and width of my logo has done wonders,
and that’s the type of thing this course
will teach you.
These days you can teach yourself pretty much
any skill online and Skillshare is a fantastic
place to do it.
With professional and understandable classes,
that follow a clear learning curve, you can
dive in and start learning how to do the work
you love.
.
A Premium Membership begins around $10 a month
for unlimited access to all courses, but the
first 1000 people to sign up with this link
will get their first 2 months for free.
So ask yourself right now.
What skill have you been putting off learning.
What project have you been dreaming of completing,
but you aren’t sure if you have the skills
to do it.
Why not start right now and sign up to Skillshare
using the link below to get your first 2 months
free.
You have nothing to lose and a valuable life
skill to gain.
As usual thanks for watching and thank you
to all my Patreon supporters.
If you would like to see more from me, the
links to my twitter, facebook, discord server,
subreddit and instagram pages are below.